on va aller au dos à dos autre exercice
doit dos à dos à dos à dos deux ados
avec vous pape diouf et des réponse du
tac au tac s'il vous plaît la devise de
l'om
quelle est la vôtre il court toujours
quel est votre juron préféré gros merde
est ce que vous payez lié à seysses j'ai
eu à la paix êtes vous capable de vous
fâcher définitivement avec quelqu'un oui
est ce que vous prenez des
antidépresseurs non je fumais beaucoup
jusqu'à un paquet et demi par jour mais
depuis un an et demi j'ai arrêté de
fumer
la dernière fois que vous avez soufflé
dans le ballon jamais parce que je ne
bois jamais d'alcool pas une goutte
d'alcool depuis le de tout le temps je
n'ai jamais bu d'alcool
n'êtes vous pas un joueur de football
refoulé en définitive non absolument pas
je n'ai pas de frustration de ce pôle
est ce que vous aimeriez voir les
paroles de la marseillaise changé
peut-être il ya quand même quelques
propos assez guerrier dans ce dans ce
set
non c'était vous parvenez à la chanter
très peu est ce que vous êtes arrivé de
pleurer pour une défaite
non mais 2.2 vraie crise oui et pour une
victoire pas encore mais j'espère que ce
sera ailleurs
est ce que vous dites facilement je
t'aime il faut marcher ça de la bouche
oui et ça arrive de temps en temps
sérieux quelles tâches ménagères vous
donne le plus de satisfaction mais à une
époque c'était faire la cuisine en fait
de faire la vaisselle mais depuis que
j'ai un problème de dos la vaisselle
impôts - la cuisine quand jamais
l'occasion ou et révolté la dernière
fois que vous avez étaler votre culture
il faudrait que j'aie déjà la conscience
d'avoir cette culture donc je ne pense
vraiment pas avoir eu l'occasion de
l'étaler c'est votre pierre tombale vous
voulez
un ballon ou des versets du coran les
deux le 2 les deux vous irez tout à fait
[Musique]